[Music]
hey what is up guys MTV HD here happy
Thanksgiving and welcome to Q&A number
22
aka number 11 of 12 for this year 2017
we've done it every month
it's November one more after this and
then we'll see where it goes so I asked
you guys on Twitter as I usually do what
you wanted to know and side note if you
aren't already following on Twitter
you're definitely gonna want to do that
in the next couple days I don't want to
say too much but that's about all
giveaway I'll link it below so Andris
wants to know thoughts on net neutrality
situation so honestly I have a lot of
thoughts on this whole net neutrality
thing first of all
okay if that bothered you even a little
bit then you should brush up on the
whole net neutrality vote that's
happening yet again it's almost
unbelievable that we continue to have
this debate but at the same time it is
kind of believable so it's happening
again I'll link below the beste guide or
information portal that I can find to
explain everything but bottom line it
sucks
Shen asks what are your top games in the
past month that you've played on that
bad ass omen that's a great question
I think the most common like the most
amount of playtime I've actually put
into a game is actually probably that VR
game super hot The Omen is set up right
now as our HTC vive set up and in that
little area over there we've played a
game called super hot which is basically
a game of like dodging bullets but time
only moves when you move so you can
choose when to dodge things it's really
exciting and fun to play I also played a
game called project cars we got a wheel
for it we got a pedal it's paddle
shifting it's the whole deal it's pretty
fun but uh that high refresh rate
monitor over there is killing it with
the omen a lot of fun Black Friday
question mark question mark or cyber
monday question mark yeah I'm gonna go
with cyber monday on this one and again
I don't want to say too much but you're
probably gonna want to follow on Twitter
wink wink
on your razor video you had rocket
League wallpaper do you enjoy playing
the game what's your rank if any I
didn't know there was ranks or was it
just a coincidence for the yeah I've
played rocket League a little bit now
the catch is I actually play it most
often on my ps4 Pro on the wallpaper TV
so I play the console version but that's
what I'm familiar with the controls with
now and I think I've gotten pretty good
at it it's mostly my defense that has
earned me a rep I don't score very much
I don't know my rank but that is a fun
game and they can it look like I have
tons of time for games now I really
still don't I don't game that much like
I've played pub G twice ever
haven't won yet I'm just saying my
Instagram feed three days ago three day
this guy's made a very good use of the
extra character as you get on Twitter
now but I agree with you dude I actually
hate that Instagram moves things out of
chronological order that's one of the
reasons I like Twitter and hate the
stock Twitter app is because things get
shuffled I want to make sure I see
everything and the only way to do that
is to go in order from top to bottom or
bottom to top I wish there was an option
Instagram I could turn that off but
there isn't I hate it this guy said why
should I ask a question to be in the vid
I see what you did there despite all the
positivity surrounding the Roadster -
what's one thing you aren't a fan of
that's a good question there's a lot of
hype surrounding that car of course I
think the one thing most people will
point to is the interior it's so not
like any other supercar I don't know if
you've ever seen the inside of a
Lamborghini Aventador or a McLaren or
pretty much any high-end supercar like
that definitely way different the Tesla
has more of a spaceship vibe gone with
it but that still doesn't speak to every
car person but my one complaint would
actually be I wish shows a little more a
little more carbon-fiber
a little more actual carbon fiber parts
but that's just me Muhammad says why
don't you shoot an 18 by 9 dude I've
thought about it a lot I don't know if
you've seen I'll link Jon's
TLD today his his iPhone 10 review was
shot in two by one and he doesn't even
shooting two by one that much but he did
and there were so many shots in it that
made me go now I want to shooted two by
one that looks like fun and the
conversation around content is well if
all of our phones if all of our screens
in our pockets are gonna be two by one
now then we might as well start making
these two by one aspect ratio videos
which look really cool but I still think
the majority of people will watch it on
computers will watch it on TVs and of
course phones are very popular but I
don't think there's gonna be any problem
with shooting 16 by 9 at least for the
time being Armando says would you ever
go on to the h3 podcast if you were
invited no I would never go of course I
would go on the h3 podcast bas 3m says
how many terabytes did you record slash
upload this month while I only upload
the final version which is 5 6 gigs tops
per video but how many terabytes that I
record this
I would actually have to go back and
check which I'll do that but my guests
before I go back and check would be I
would I'm gonna go with about five
terabytes let's go with five
[Music]
can you put us on to some of your
favorite ultimate tech gear are there
any high tech frisbees you know what I
actually tend to be like the opposite of
a tech person when I'm playing ultimate
a lot of people wear like a wearable to
keep track of like their heart rate and
their steps I don't like wearing that
stuff when I play cuz it feels like in
the way and clunky so I don't have any
wearable tech I don't really like have
my phone on me obviously when I'm
playing the closest thing I can think of
is like the cameras and the footage that
people use to record ultimate which is
like the super sweet slow-mo clips but
yeah there's there's really not that
much tech as far as ultimate goes that I
really know of hey but if you want to
watch a bunch of really sweet super
slow-motion ultimate basically highlight
reels where it's really good quality
ultimate and really good quality footage
this channel that I'll link below is an
amazing combination of that if you can
go check it out that would be awesome
prepare to have your mind blown out of
your face well says are you getting the
iMac Pro yeah the thing is like I've
thought about this more
they Apple when they announced iMac Pro
they said December I'm pretty sure for
this year but then they said the new
modular Mac Pro that they're also gonna
make was 2018 so next year and when I
saw that I kind of figured like oh well
you know that's just December and then
January we'll get that right afterward
but that's probably not what's gonna
happen 2018 probably means like November
December of next year so I think I'm at
pro Wolff for me be the workhorse for
that time and I probably will end up
moving to the Mac Pro but I'm gonna give
the on Mac Pro a shot rumors are already
circulating of course about the next
iPhone and its name what do you think
Apple will call it and what would you
like to see in the next iPhone also how
do you think Apple will design it I kind
of think we'll see like a similar iPhone
10 to this year but I do want to see an
iPhone 10 plus but what do they call it
is it just iPhone 11 there been rumors
that they'll stick with an IPS iPhone
and an OLED iPhone again side by side so
like iPhone 9 and iPhone 11 but that
what happens when the IPS one moves to
ten do you do that
they don't that's a good point that is a
good point yeah it's not the move well
we always have these questions of apples
naming schemes but they always seem to
pull it off so uh I guess we'll just
wait and see the detroit borg says every
year seems to have a trend and he's
right 2017 was the year of no bezels
what will define 2018 phones and I know
look I can't tell the future so I'm just
really speculating if I guess but
there's something I really liked about
this phone the razor phone and that is
our 120 Hertz displays I would love for
every phone next year to have an hundred
twenty Hertz ola if that's even possible
I'd love it but what I really honestly
think we'll start to define phones of
next year is artificial intelligence
adding features via software there were
low key a lot of things in this past
year that became possible because of
machine learning and AI that weren't in
previous phones the portrait mode from
the front-facing camera
the incredible single lens rear facing
portrait mode from the pixel to the dot
projector from the iPhone 10 and face ID
all that stuff even though an emoji
seemed really dumb again a lot of this
stuff was only possible through machine
learning SAP says your top 5 social
media platforms in order I'm assuming
you're talking about like my favorites
favorite ones in which case it would be
Twitter I guess would be number one
Instagram wait does eat is a YouTube a
social network can i I probably put yeah
YouTube's a social network so YouTube
number one Twitter number two Instagram
number three and then I guess I got to
go Facebook number for Google+ number
five
sorry snapchat I put it away that's
where I'm gonna end it thank you for
your questions and thank you for
watching this Q&A video one more for
this year and again if you're not
already following on Twitter I don't
know what you're doing open a new tab
hit that okay that's about it thanks
talk to you in the next one peace
[Music]